not a [ __ ] really it's not a good
idea
hey look look who we got here look what
we got here look who decided to show up
we're talking about an alpha cuck here
and uh you know of course the guy the
guy can't handle his microphone
typical game say say hi to everyone
say hi to gabe everyone even though he
can't say hi back i can say hi back i
can talk i hear you're talking about
these schmucks oh yes yes yes brian
schwa is it suave or is it suave
i think it's
it's salve salve salve right like ryan
alpha cuck is what is
[Music]
yeah yeah yeah yeah but he puts an
accent on the ears yeah well yeah
whether that was
a real whether whether that was a
fabricated you know or like
created by him or not i don't know
hey
what's everyone saying hi gabe
hi gabe hello gabe what's up hey what's
up welcome gabe to the to the the tony
michaels podcast uh but yeah he's the
executive producer and co-host of the
show i'm trying to give you like an
intro i don't know maybe we should have
like a gabe intro like music or some
[ __ ]
yeah i don't know what that would be you
could run in like kevin mccarthy ran
away from a reporter
maybe i'll let the audience uh maybe the
you know what how about you guys throw
out some suggestions as to what my intro
music if i have any should be there you
go like like a like a wrestling bam
right right you know like you enter them
yeah like and every day i'll i'll
actually light live fireworks off in my
bedroom and right now
hopefully my landlord isn't watching
this well you know
you know
so um so so what do you think about this
guys if this guy's tweet is spot on you
know he's talking to dear ladies and
then at the end what is the your
brothers what does that mean is it like
man i think it's it's see here's the
thing like he's this he's this pastor
right or this uh
whatever that christian
friend oh i'm sure it's a fantastic
church right right i think what he means
is like you're brothers because as a
pastor he's like oh we're all brothers
and sisters so he's saying as you know
as your respected brothers
please respect your body
and
uh do not do this don't show the newborn
baby don't show the weight loss don't
show the birth story also didn't you
just show a photo of him saying like
whatever how many weeks his wife was
pregnant yeah so uh well kaelin is it is
it difficult
is it different is it different because
he said he shared it he shared it she
didn't share it right is that the is
that the death that is the difference
yeah it's well yeah absolutely men have
the right to be on social media sharing
whatever photo naked photos of women
that they want or pregnant photos or
their weight loss story men can do that
women can't right yeah that you know
there is
yeah i really love the double standard
that we've got this guy who is a
you know practicing follower of christ
yeah yeah yeah yeah has to put up these
uh restrictions as to what a woman can
and can't do it's like it's uh what it's
their body it's their [ __ ] choice
okay right
don't come in and get all [ __ ] butt
hurt because you got a little aroused or
a little jealous right or envious that's
what this is
they don't want boners they're scared of
boners it makes them feel like you know
like oh i get all this this feeling
right and when i get a boner they're so
[ __ ] scared of sex because here's the
thing because like you know i grew up in
the catholic church and you know study
christians
right and so like
there was a point where like i got one
side of the church and then i got a
different side of the church
and i'll tell you this
it's all [ __ ] it's all terrible because
you mean the catholic church are just
christianity in general just like you've
got catholicism you know the
righteousness the pompous attitude the
entitlement i remember privilege yeah
yeah and then there's christianity which
in some ways i almost find even worse
because it's like a new age uh uh like
privilege and
and pompous attitude that people have
like i you know i was a part of a
christian youth group in high school
and to a degree it was fun and it was
great but at the same time there are
also moments when people be like oh i'm
better than this other person because
i'm you know i'm a follower of christ
even though i would see those people say
vile vulgar [ __ ] uh you know no
different than what joe rogan would say
and we would be like hey that's not cool
like no that's cool school i go to
church and god forgives me it's like
that's not how that works right that's
that's you can't just like wash away the
sins by saying oh it's all good god will
get me on sunday like
he doesn't that's not how it works
i wonder if the twitter gods are gonna
forgive him for this tweet here that
he's posting of a pregnant woman right
now i mean 2013 crazy you know nine
years nine years ago you know
almost a nine nine year anniversary
crazy he definitely did not remember
that he posted a picture of his pregnant
lady when i but when i see stuff where
someone's like oh you're brothers like
okay first off don't speak on behalf of
the rest of us right right exactly like
you are not
as uh
as great as you may seem right or or
like you might be able to stand by the
pulpit and the lectern and speak out to
the rest of the people in your church
and give them the the stories and and
try to connect the different symbolism
and all this to different parts of the
story that you made up and how it
relates to this and that here's the
thing shut the [ __ ] up okay just shut
the [ __ ] up life would be a lot easier
if religion was not a problem or not not
a thing because obviously that's the
forefront of a lot of issues in in our
in our history throughout the world's
history and when we've got people that
are trying to
position themselves their uh
priorities their ideologies whatever
politics on to someone else to say
you shouldn't do this because x y z well
what happened to the actual the the the
aspect of free will right right freedom
freedom
i can't yeah it's like i can't do this
on my own
my own free will my own freedom i i
can't choose
myself on my own my own body
my mind my spirit like these are all
things that they preach and they and
they
practice
but then they'll
they'll push on to other people and say
you're not good enough because you
didn't accept christ you're not good
enough because you did not
do not just dissolve yourself of all
your ego and your your righteousness and
say i
am just a a child of god and a follower
of christ and shut the [ __ ] up okay if
you are going to be hypocritical you're
double standard [ __ ] and you're
going to say in your home versus on the
street versus in the church if it's not
consistent
then shut the [ __ ] up but also
stop telling people what to [ __ ] do
right you know and they that's the [ __ ]
that they do they claim that we're
trying to force them to do all these
things and
liberals are the fascist and they're
trying to force you to do like shut the
that's not even close to what is
happening right and and you can see it
in the ratio here right like look at the
[ __ ] quote tweets this guy got like
almost eighteen thousand glow tweets now
i'm not gonna go down because there's
nudity in these in these things oh yeah
so so youtube would [ __ ] would kick
this video um which i want this video to
live on for a long time for this [ __ ]
idiot yeah but but the crazy so what
here's what i did last night i'm like oh
[ __ ] this [ __ ] i'm gonna go through and
i'm gonna i liked as many pictures as
women were posting as i possibly could
like i went down and hearted all of them
boom boom boom i didn't give a [ __ ] what
it was showing who what what the reason
i just
liked all of them as many as i could but
there's like there's a lot of them
there's thousands of them and what i
would recommend
what i would recommend is don't go to
this post and don't go like all those
pictures and make sure
oh brian here knows that his brothers
aren't who he who aren't who they he
thinks they are we're not your [ __ ]
your i'm not your [ __ ] brother [ __ ]
i'm not yours brian brian
salve
is the type of guy
that would [ __ ] jerk it alongside
josh hawley right tight grip pornhub
kind of guy
that's who they are right again they are
the type of person that
temptation is is the worst thing and
they were afraid of it and they won't
accept it because temptation can be good
depending on how you you know go about
it but
this guy as well as many others within
the christian faith in that cult
look at it and they say well if i can't
enjoy it neither can you
and that's what it is in a day they're
jealous and they're envious that other
people actually are able to
express themselves and explore their
sexuality and their bodies and their
minds and their own actual freedom and
not feel like they're shackled to this
christianity hypocritical mindset that
you've got to be one thing or the other
and you can't be bold and there's no
gray area it's either black or white
right or wrong left or right that's what
it is
right and that's what these people
talk right alpha cup exactly i i mean i
don't i don't think our intention or
your intention when you said that out
loud was to like like oh my god that
works so [ __ ] great but it just it
just it just came out i was like that
guy's an alpha like that's that was not
planned that's exactly but that's
exactly what is happening here speaking
alpha cux i know you want to talk about
this because i know that you um you have
received your fair amount of trolls um
and even even um in the last few days uh
people were saying racist [ __ ] about you
in comments right yeah um and we've seen
we've seen this joe rogan [ __ ] where and
i think it was because you called out
joe rogan wasn't it yeah i mean yeah
well it was a
yeah yeah yeah it was i mean you you
called him out you you called him out
and they were right
because he was saying
right i called him out and i called
republicans and i said the republic
can party kkk you know party
uh
are more upset
with joe rogan being called out for
being racist than joe rogan actually
being racist
meanwhile i go i like post it i go to
[ __ ] trader joe's with my girlfriend
we're going to get you know groceries
for the week meanwhile my messages are
blowing up and i've got people that are
like saying oh i'm wrong and joe rogan
works with black people and he's got
black friends so he can't be racist yeah
the black friendship like right gang did
exactly and then they're they're pushing
down and uh they're like oh why don't
you call out these people that people
and i'm like i'm glad they're getting
called out right left right wherever
they are on the political spectrum
if they say the n-word or say racist
stuff they should be called out yeah
call them out and see what their
response is right they're responses like
joe rogan so they [ __ ] you right and i
you know into these people i even
commented to a couple and i said hey i'm
this is great i'm glad they're getting
called out they should be held
accountable i'm glad we both agreed that
it should be fair on both sides and
they're like oh well that's not exactly
what's happening and i was like
okay somebody made videos i support
these videos if they're calling out as
an example of what people said that was
racist they said the n-word or they said
something that was vulgar or that was
derogatory or whatever was we should be
held to the same standard right now
whether the full public
follows that is whatever but if
individual by individual i support that
if someone said that they should be
called out for it so people got really
upset and then of course people came in
calling me
uh
[Music]
corny my corny ass but with that they
were saying like oh i hope you get
deported i hope you do this oh oh you
know obviously because because of your
last name right because i happen to be
mexican all of a sudden the assumption
is that i'm here illegally right and
that's your last name is sanchez right
oh oh boy oh boy look at this guy you
know it doesn't even matter if i was
born in this country not wish i was by
the way but you know that's regardless
well i mean you know you know it's you
know what's funny about the that type of
racism it's like all the people in the
southwest part of the country like ah
like that used to be mexico like we
stole it from them like how don't you
know that that mexican descendants of
mexicans are he were here before you
were right wrong before you were also
making the argument that we stole it
from mexico that's also doesn't make you
sound great like right
you keep tell you keep trying to brag
about how you stole land right
indigenous people right exactly you know
like my my ancestors as well like it it
doesn't make you conquered you right it
doesn't make you sound as cool as you
think it does
especially when you're talking about
like raping and pillaging and destroying
it like you know mexico city was an
advanced civilization and then the
spaniards came in and basically [ __ ] on
it and right burned it down and tore it
down and you know anyway the the point
is i've got these people who are coming
in and saying joe rogan isn't racist but
then saying racist [ __ ] to me as a way
to defend joe rogan right like he's not
racist so i'm gonna say racist [ __ ] and
defensively
so it's like i i i i'm not trying to i
like i don't understand what your logic
is are you you're trying to cover up
one racist remark with another racist
remark like
what what the [ __ ] is wrong with you and
we've seen this we've seen this reach a
high temperature because right um with
the joe rogan stuff patriot takes uh put
out a video uh which was an alex jones
video that alex jones made when he was
in a feud with joe rogan they were
pissed off at each other so uh alex
jones decided to get even with joe rogan
and post a video on the internet where
he's saying the n word over and over and
over again and then another video about
uh
that's a time that joe rogan describes
how he went to watch planet of the apes
and he described when he got out of the
car there were black people there and he
felt like he was in africa and he was on
the planet of the apes
you know just racist [ __ ] tropes
right they think it's funny they you
know they were i'm a comedian you know
they hide behind this than veil but the
the issue is is that
um on the internet that they they
actually drew in the mizella's brothers
which the mizella's brothers anyone not
that doesn't know out there and they
don't hide it they're jewish right
they're they're jewish and they they
they started and run midas touch
midastouch.com the mind is touch network
in full disclosure we worked with mind
as touch just last week on distributing
an interview and and to be to be frank
with you i i talked to the mizellas
brothers
almost every week
but they're good guys they're good guys
they're doing good pro-democracy work in
this country whether you like it or not
which really if you don't like their
pro-democracy work that says something
more about you than it probably does
about them
but here's the thing is that
uh
it's a discount local and i don't know
and i don't know who the vocal is and it
doesn't [ __ ] matter who vocal is it
doesn't [ __ ] matter it's some [ __ ]
twitter account some [ __ ] anti-semite
probably who is going around accusing
people of being in a cabal which has
that [ __ ] trope of anti-semitism to
it right
so
what happens is is dave portnoy i don't
know if you guys know that [ __ ] alpha
cuck but that [ __ ] decides to
retweet and to blast this stuff and to
put it on and to give it to feed it to
his audience which his audience is full
of a bunch of alpha cuts so let's just
be frank white fragile males who can't
handle the [ __ ] truth that they're
pieces of [ __ ] and their ideas are [ __ ]
they just can't handle it oh we like
sports and we want to beat our chest and
we think it's cool shut the [ __ ] up you
are not tough at all right so what
happens is is dave portnoy puts this on
blast and what the mizellas do brothers
do is the the strong thing for a man to
do say hey that's cool you want to have
a conversation let's have a conversation
man-to-man let's do this let's talk to
each other um they go on um to youtube
and of course we played it i think
yesterday or the day before um but they
go on youtube they talked it out sort of
uh dave portnoy
actually accused one of them
um of of saying the n-word right he said
he had proof and i didn't provide the
proof because he probably doesn't
[ __ ] have proof and even and then he
doesn't prove he can't verify the [ __ ]
exactly and not only that but even they
even brought it up and talked about it
in
the podcast
uh this week
and they discussed this whole thing and
the bar school whatever the [ __ ] this
thing no no i'm saying might as touches
oh okay yeah yeah they discussed it this
week to explain what happened they're
like right
right well because because the the
accusation is because midas touch
retweeted something they're the ones
behind all the rogan [ __ ] right and of
course this local account you know
these white me these fragile white males
get in these threads and they get boners
about uh jewish people being behind this
big thing to take down white people
right it's it's got white supremacy all
over it yep and local i wouldn't be
surprised if they got a nazi flag
hanging in their [ __ ] bedroom right
would not surprise me one [ __ ] bit
this whole targeted attack that they've
had against myself brothers like you
know
is exactly that's the funny part is it's
a target attack against them is what
they're right and what they're accusing
them of doing to joe rogan right right
[ __ ] joe rogan he's a [ __ ] racist
live with it live with joe rogan just
because they ex just because they
retweeted a [ __ ] video that exposes
that your favorite [ __ ] podcaster is
a [ __ ] racist
you gotta live with that [ __ ]
you no
no but you can't live with that that
makes sense that makes them upset the
fact that they're they're uh comedian
leader they're they're they're woke
brash blunt tells it how it is kind of
guy you know every [ __ ] joe rogan
he's a [ __ ] dip said racist stuff oh
no dude that's not cool that's an attack
against them because they take it
personally that's right they take it as
an attack against their leader and that
their their dude is an attack against it
which is similar to the trumpism mindset
which is like you attack him you attack
me right that's that's because that's
because they don't they don't see joe
rogan when he's doing his show as a
comedian and that [ __ ] hiding behind
comedy and [ __ ]
is just [ __ ] uh absolute [ __ ]
because they're his audience and port
noise audience because portnoy did the
same [ __ ] stupid thing on the goddamn
conversation that he had with the
mizella's brother i do comedy it's
supposed to be funny
well that's fine that's fine and all but
it's not comedy your audience doesn't
see this comedy and the reason why they
don't see it as comedy they see it
seriously is because they're calling
making phone calls to the mizellas
brothers and threatening to kill them
which is a [ __ ] crime you can't you
can't do that that's not a thing you can
do these people who think that it's
crazy because the other part of it is
like also portnoy is jewish so it's a
lot of his followers
are doing these they're like well i like
him he's jewish so these things aren't
anti-semitic
it's the same thing of like well i can't
be racist because i've got a black
friend it's important always saying oh
well this wasn't racist when we had this
podcast because they're black employees
of mine i i it's like
the insanity uh the the [ __ ]
twisted messed up mindset that people
have where it's like well i have an
affiliation or association with this one
group so i can't actually be this thing
that's against them i can't be uh racist
or derogatory or whatever or just a joke
like how was that thing
set like how is that racist how how is
how is that unfair to them how is that
derogatory right it's a compliment it's
like
you know joe rogan going on the podcast
and saying like well how is it racist if
i say that uh that asian people are
smart at math like how is it racist if i
say uh so many jewish people are nobel
laureates or geniuses
like you're
i don't ah [ __ ] man well and you know
you know what gets me is because the my
zealous brothers actually defended joe
rogan for him being racist on his
podcast they actually created a speech
he could say
two days before we want to compete with
these ideas because we think our ideas
will our our our pro-democracy message
will beat the racist dividing message
right like that's what they said let him
[ __ ] continue on spotify and i i kind
of feel the same [ __ ] way if joe
rogan wants to speak into a microphone
fine if spotify doesn't find it
profitable then they'll take him down
which i think is gonna happen and the
reason why is because we had such big
names that have way bigger microphones
than joe rogan enter the chat like
dwayne the rock johnson right i think
that's he's got a way bigger microphone
speaking against rogan has such more of
an impact than a music artist like neil
young taking down their music right
which brings me to this this kind of
this tweet here uh minus touch posted
this this morning last night after
receiving hundreds of hateful and
anti-semitic emails and dms following
the right-wing smear
campaign
members of midas touch were the target
of death threats the perpetrator made
dozens of phone calls to us our families
and our significant others um actually
you know let's go [ __ ] listen to this
thing i actually posted uh i posted a
clip from last night's
conversation right they said they'll
play more of it i think tomorrow on the
podcast but uh
i listened to it last night um
well and here's here's the thing and
brett is the one who posted uh dear dan
it says i've got your name your number
and your home address i'll be calling
you so yeah this is the origin this is
the first one and then there's the
follow-up one where he actually had a
conversation he recorded it too oh
really okay so where's the follow-up one
this one here uh no no this is the this
is the
warning one that they had well let's
play this one let's play this one here
let's play this one from brit cause i
think the one it's in that thread that
he has it too okay
let's play this one
watch out for yourself [ __ ]
watch out for yourself [ __ ]
so it's very simple he's just pulling
out phrases let's see you said is this
it here there you go boom
okay uh let's see
you with your daddy
you think you're a tough guy damn
no is there something you want to say
is there something you want to man up to
right now man to ma'am
wait a second wait a second
you know what's funny about this dan
thinks he's so [ __ ] tough that he's
gonna pick on a mizella's brother
because he's some kind of [ __ ] [ __ ]
or some [ __ ] like that he thinks i'll
just call and leave a message i'll [ __ ]
with this guy i'll make him i'll make
him go
it's not just because he left voicemails
and messages for other family members
and other friends
yeah but brett picked up the [ __ ]
phone let's listen no no i think brett
called him yep oh bro he called his dad
as well from what i understand oh okay i
got you are you do you apologize
i do
are you gonna call everybody who you
called and send text messages and
profusely apologize for what you've done
this is your chance i'm not i'm not mad
at you i'm just talking to you man to
man you don't call somebody you don't
call somebody's wife you don't threaten
them and harass them
i i didn't threaten anyone you told me
to hang myself
you said you were coming for me so
i did i did not i ha i haven't recorded
actually and so you could either
apologize man to man say you're sorry to
me apologize to everybody you called
take it back
i'm gonna have to take the necessary
action call the authorities right after
this phone call
[Music]
all right well you call everybody back
who you called you know you missed calls
man up about this be a man [ __ ] alpha
cuck little [ __ ]
you got caballed [ __ ] danno you
little [ __ ]
here's the thing here's the thing these
[ __ ] idiots out there think that that
liberals aren't [ __ ] tough and
liberals won't come after you liberals
won't stand up for themselves you're
[ __ ] wrong you're dead [ __ ] wrong
there's right and there's wrong and this
is [ __ ] wrong to call someone's
[ __ ] family because of something they
said now i don't get this me and you
have talked about this i don't get this
kind of [ __ ] i don't get this racist
[ __ ] [ __ ]
turned around on me because i'm a white
dude with a goddamn beard
i don't get that [ __ ] and there's a
reason for it there's a reason for it
and it's because they're [ __ ] racist
not not just rogan and portnoy himself
and the it's the [ __ ] people that
they hire it's the messages that they
send and it's the [ __ ] trumpets that
they send out to these [ __ ] alpha
cuts and their goddamn stooly army and
they're [ __ ] roganites right
[ __ ]
that's what we're talking about when
you're saying this [ __ ] about
misinformation and disinformation and
spreading it around
these people think it's okay no this is
not [ __ ] okay they think it's okay
that they can call someone they can
threaten them they can harass their
family this is the type of [ __ ] that
we had the last four years that trump
was like yeah you kicked their ass yeah
we're gonna do the son of a [ __ ] that's
the type of thing we let the [ __ ]
boogeyman out of the closet and now he
won't go back in and now everyone thinks
that it is okay in society to do this
type of [ __ ] not like they weren't doing
it before but now people are gonna do it
and then on the phone call well i didn't
say that i didn't do it oh we have a
recorded call well i don't remember
exactly who i called or what i said shut
the [ __ ] up you just made a death threat
you threatened to have someone kill
themselves and then now you're [ __ ]
scared like a little [ __ ] [ __ ]
because you got called out because brett
called your dad and made you [ __ ]
apologize on the phone
that's right let's listen to the rest of
this oh i will all right this could be a
learning moment for you all right you
don't call strangers and do that [ __ ]
all right so i
i think i called this number and
spammed it and i apologize
spammed it
spammed it what the [ __ ] you he called
he called him multiple times he still he
still can't even man up and say what the
[ __ ] he did
what a bunch of [ __ ] [ __ ]
what a bunch of [ __ ] little [ __ ]
punk ass [ __ ] the snowflakes baby
they are
melting away you [ __ ] alpha cucks
oh you're the one who threatened me
before
i i didn't mean that because i thought
i'm just curious like honestly like why
did you think that was okay
i didn't think it was so good
so why did you i mean you called me it
wasn't like you called me once
accidentally called me like i'm not
trying to give you a hard time i'm just
trying to like have an honest
conversation like man-to-man like you
thought it was okay to call me nine
times you thought it was okay to call my
wife you thought it was okay to call my
brother like like what i just honestly
like man-to-man like what what is it
like like just tell me i'll talk to you
about it
it was it was not it was not okay
and um
it was
inappropriate you can hear the [ __ ]
crying oh yes
well i mean
and that's i mean that's fair i mean
that the thing is is that he knows
there's going to be consequences right
he knows there's going to be [ __ ]
consequences you think you can just call
up and threaten somebody's life in your
[ __ ] parents basement and then once
your parents get the [ __ ] call on
their [ __ ] landline phone or their
cell phone and they say hey can i talk
to uh can i talk to daniel is this
daniel's dad and they're like yeah yeah
why oh well your son [ __ ] threatened
my life what are you talking about oh
here's a recording oh holy [ __ ] all
right let's get him
brings him out and calls him on and
talks him on the phone meanwhile i love
the fact that brett's like man to man
let's talk man to man right i want to
say this man to man because at the end
of the day they're he's not a man he's a
[ __ ] he's a boy he's you know insecure
you know
ass [ __ ] you know
born and bred in a world that said it
was okay to do this but when it comes to
you know
actually
yeah confronted with the consequences of
your actions thinking that oh you know
what the internet's anonymous oh i'm
gonna call this person and i'm gonna i'm
gonna i'm gonna do this anonymously oh
well you [ __ ] idiot you left your
voice you left you let your [ __ ] you
didn't even make it anonymous you just
called and and made it a miscall and
then you called multiple times and then
you use that same number to call other
people and [ __ ] threaten them and
harass them and you think there's not
gonna be consequences you think this is
what playing call of duty you could just
say [ __ ] online and not have to worry
about any sort of any sort of issue or
or consequence to the actions that you
made no buddy no no no no no you're
[ __ ] you are [ __ ] and now
you're becoming infamous
right well let me tell you something
that i i don't care what the political
affiliation is
no one should have their family members
called threatened i don't give a [ __ ]
who they are you should not have your
family members called your personal
calls and threaten your [ __ ] life and
and try to make you scare you into
changing what you're doing with your
political opinion we have political
opinions in this country we have the
[ __ ] right to them and you don't get
to threaten someone with their life or
their family's life
to try to to try to silence them i don't
care who the [ __ ] they are i don't care
if it's the my zealous brothers i don't
care if it's portnoy himself i don't
give a [ __ ]
you don't [ __ ] do that [ __ ] this is a
free [ __ ] country you are welcome to
your [ __ ] your your goddamn political
affiliations and your political thoughts
you can be a [ __ ] racist you can be a
[ __ ] racist dano
you can love the racism that is spewed
on rogan's show and your little stooly
shows
and your [ __ ] macho machismo [ __ ]
which dano it's not macho machismo it's
not it's not manly it's a you're a bunch
of punk ass [ __ ] listen to a a bunch
of punk-ass [ __ ] like rogan and and
and [ __ ] portnoy those [ __ ]
wouldn't stand up for a goddamn woman
wouldn't stand up for someone trying to
be who they want to be because they're a
bunch of goddamn punk-ass [ __ ]
and it really pisses me off and i don't
care who it is what it is
i don't care if what your political
affiliation is what your sexuality is
what the [ __ ] color your skin is i
don't give a [ __ ]
you don't do that type of [ __ ] this is a
free goddamn country you're welcome to
your [ __ ] ideas you're welcome to
your political opinions and and we can
have this out in the in the [ __ ]
arena of free speech you don't [ __ ]
threaten someone's family you don't call
and threaten someone with their [ __ ]
lives you don't do that [ __ ] yeah and to
use
and to use a a political affiliation as
an excuse right or your anti-semitism
and your in your bigotry and your racism
is [ __ ] disgusting right you little
dick energy alpha cuck looking head ass
right yep that's it that's it yeah
i mean i i don't even know how else more
to explain this and and again i'm i i
know the my zealous brothers i i like
that we've had them on our show that's
how we entered the [ __ ] chat exactly
because they thought it was a [ __ ]
gotcha we were playing [ __ ] sports
trivia and they're like look at these
guys they're behind it all you're
talking about stopping the steel and all
this [ __ ] they they went on this podcast
and revealed themselves behind the
[ __ ] curtain what the [ __ ] are you
talking about shut the [ __ ] up i don't
understand you're ignorant you're
bigoted you're racist you're sexist
misogynistic
shut the [ __ ] up okay the other the
other thing too about this story that is
just [ __ ] laughable is how
how they switched from
somehow midas touch had this coordinated
attack against joe rogan to the entire
attack now is towards my like towards
mind and stuff it's like the whole
attack like
they retweeted a few things these people
are calling these [ __ ] giving
them death threats
death threats i i seriously doubt
because i know a lot of the midas money
i really seriously doubt that the midas
mighty went and said anything to portnoy
or any of the stoolies that was to the
level of threatening them or their
families lives yeah they they will go
and i know the mind is mighty they'll go
into a political arena and have it out
with you now rather it be in a chat or
elsewhere they will definitely they will
definitely try to beat your ass at the
ballot box and they should be
they should be you don't [ __ ] you don't
[ __ ] with people who are who are
passionate politically especially dano
if you don't know a [ __ ] thing about
politics all you want to do is listen to
your little little white races down in
austin texas called joe rogan just
listen to him listen to him have your
deep-seated racism live with it you know
no one's stopping you right stop being
such a little punk ass don't don't
[ __ ] have someone at all
don't [ __ ] backpedal once you get
called out once you literally get a call
from the person that you threatened
their life
and then say oh uh i i did i don't know
who i i'm just shut the [ __ ] up you made
an action and there's a consequence for
it okay you can't take you can't
backpedal and try to excuse yourself and
make something up as to why it's okay or
why that was just a joke or why you were
just messing around no no no once you
start going against people and
threatening their lives it becomes
serious [ __ ] [ __ ] that's right well
and when it gets serious that's when
they get snowflakey and they run away
and they cry on the phone for their
daddy
logical says here on twitch uh midas
leads the way s sucks this happened to
its members only gives them more fuel to
continue to forward their message and i
think that's that's the other thing that
they the big miscalculation from portnoy
rogan and their [ __ ] followers is
that somehow this is gonna make them go
away you people are [ __ ] dumb
right we are we again we have been
affiliated with minus touch in this last
week because we actually they partnered
with us on the distribution of the tasha
adams and dakota adams
interview they helped us with that so
we've been officially
affiliated with him but they don't tell
me what to say
they don't [ __ ] i've never i've never
got a conversation with one of them
saying what'd you say how'd you say it
they didn't even question what the [ __ ]
it was that was in the goddamn interview
when we went and sold it to him they
knew they knew it was a pro-democracy
message because they know that's what we
do and that's what our [ __ ] aim is
and you [ __ ] out there
just wanting to promote racism and have
have your racism have it you can have it
just go crawl back underneath your
[ __ ] rock yeah and the one thing the
last thing i'll say on this is at the
end of the day portnoy tries to to go
after the myself brothers and midas
touch and so does his vocal account and
other people right and along the way it
begins building up and building up and
building up into an anti-semitic uh type
of rhetoric right which is insane right
because it started from these guys are
doing an attack oh and then they had
they had messages like are you guys
jewish just wondering you guys are three
jewish brothers right which is like i
don't know how this is any way
associated with what's going on here but
that's the whole cabal thing right
exactly that's that [ __ ] language but
as it builds up you see that this
narrative of like they're attacking me
they're coming after me uh it's
anti-portnoy anti-joe rogan here's the
thing that's going on though because
their message is now slowly devolving
into
this anti-semitic rhetoric and death
threats that they have lost all and any
credibility that they once had because
right
even to make the argument that they're
behind it right even if they were to say
like oh they're behind all the stuff
doesn't excuse anything that you've said
anything you've threatened because now
it's just like the let's go brandon crew
at first like it's a joke it's an inside
joke well dumb whatever now it's
affiliated with [ __ ] nazis right
they're the let's go brandon crt nazis
exactly and now local and dave portnoy
are attached to this group that have
made death threats against the myself
brothers because they're jewish and they
uh have in a a partnership with patriot
takes because patriotics was getting
[ __ ] death threats right which is
great which is crazy to me that that
dave portnoy would even march down this
road because he is jewish
i just i can't even [ __ ] i mean the
the
the [ __ ] that happens here is just
beyond beyond the pale it's [ __ ] vile
and and and again it's weak and snow
flaky that they have to make these
attacks on people because of their
political beliefs if you
because portnoy even says it in the
[ __ ] conversation that they had and i
welcome dave portnoy on this show dave
if you want to come on the show fine
[ __ ] you come on i'll [ __ ] have a
conversation with you you ain't gonna
[ __ ] like it you definitely i
definitely will not [ __ ] hold back
like the mizellas they were much much
kinder to you than i ever will [ __ ]
be ever will [ __ ] be but let me tell
you something
during that conversation dave portnoy
even admitted that he's not political
and he doesn't have political beliefs
and he doesn't vote so what the [ __ ] are
you in the conversation for why are you
trying to enter the conversation well i
know why they're trying to enter the
conversation they want their army
against these [ __ ] because if you were
there during the youtube video live and
you can go watch it might as touch still
has the live chat up you can see who
they're affiliated with they're not
hiding that they're [ __ ] maga they're
not hiding that they're white
supremacist they're not hiding that they
love trump they're not they don't hide
it
it's white supremacy through and through
and that's why the attack on the
mizella's brothers has happened and
that's why they want to pile on and
actually frankly
i hate that i hate that their families
and them are getting death threats right
but at the same time i know i know
what's going to happen with the midas
mighty all right they're important and
here's the thing portnoy opened up that
[ __ ] door that's right he opened it
up and brought in jordy's uh fiance
that's right and and made that okay and
then all of those [ __ ] stully alpha
that was the point though with that
don't i think exactly that's the type
because it's the same type of [ __ ] that
trump would do we're talking about a
topic you get agitated you don't have a
good solid footing what do you do you
pivot and make an accusation then what
have you done you've distracted the
conversation from actually actual the
actual [ __ ] point the focal point the
whole thing of why they're having this
thing right not like oh well that up but
i know this text messages which ends up
being not real but you know what now
he's thrown it out there right now so it
has to be real to them right exactly
then you've got people i've got to tell
brett until brett mizellis calls your
ass and [ __ ] and says hey
[ __ ] man to man tell me what you
say right and then uh
then it's all [ __ ] it's all well that
was online that wasn't in real life no
it's real life [ __ ] and then
pisses me off go ahead i was gonna say
to tell you how insane it is just by
association i did a video uh in
partnership with midas touch last week
and i have all these comments of people
that are in there that are saying
crazy racist [ __ ] against me but also
bringing into myself brothers and
talking about jordy and whoever else but
here's the thing i just partnered with
them on a video it's just like oh you
know how you can attach two people or
three people on a instagram video well
now i've got all the [ __ ] stooly bros
coming in on that video and making [ __ ]
up about me or saying stuff you know
that i have to report or it's just dumb
idiotic but it's it's just by
association that they all of a sudden
have has said oh well here go after this
guy now because he made a video of them
what the [ __ ] is that about that's the
type of [ __ ] that this group is behind
they're trying to troll because they can
do it behind some anonymous account
well guess what you're gonna get you're
gonna get [ __ ] called out and it's
gonna happen and you're gonna [ __ ]
cry and [ __ ] and moan and say oh you
didn't mean it it was just a joke don't
be so sensitive when you're the one
who's being [ __ ] sensitive and crying
just like little dano did on the phone
that's right that's right well caitlin
makes a good point says that the the
minus money handled it with class as
always which they will they're gonna
listen if you think the midas mighty is
is not gonna fight this at the ballot
box because that's the point of the
whole [ __ ] super pac might as touch
the midas media network is pro-democracy
[ __ ] they're not talking about [ __ ]
who won the basketball game and why
someone's why why someone wears this or
where's that or or a pizza [ __ ] what
what does porno need there's pizza
reviews or some stupid [ __ ] that's not
what they're doing they're doing
democracy [ __ ] dumb [ __ ] it's politics
that's what they do that's what they do
and just because you don't like it [ __ ]
you [ __ ] them
[ __ ] them [ __ ] them [ __ ] [ __ ] them
i i and and i hate to have to come on
here again i mean this is the second or
third time that we've had to come on and
give our opinion about this and i'm not
defending them my zealous brothers
ordered my dismighty i don't have to
they will completely defend themselves
but i know this is a conversation we
have to have in the year 2022 [ __ ]
ridiculous [ __ ] insane it's
ridiculous and
that this is okay against a population
of people that is on the world is point
two percent
right right
this is not okay
and to excuse it as like well these guys
were attacking uh joe and these guys
were attacking dave portnoy go [ __ ]
cry and jerk off okay right because
that's what it is you guys go watch the
racist [ __ ] that you want to watch go
listen to the racist and be go be racist
go be racist
go do that if you want to do that you
have freedom do that don't do it down on
it but make yourself public and known
but you do not have the right you do not
have the right to [ __ ] threaten
people you do not have the right to
[ __ ] harass people you guys have the
[ __ ] right you don't have it it's not
a thing you that you are supposed to do
are allowed to do and frankly when you
step over the line like danno did it
becomes a criminal matter so [ __ ] him
[ __ ] him [ __ ] him are you are you uh
you're running out of time here i i
would say yeah i got it all right
welcome well uh stick around thanks for
staying with us say bye to gabe
everybody we'll see you maybe we'll see
you tomorrow go vote for the bone end of
the week and just a reminder just be a
good [ __ ] human yeah decent you know
you don't have to be like a good just
yeah just be censored
right right right don't make death
threats maybe respond yourself first and
then you'll respect others right maybe
that'll work stick around we'll be right
back
we'll be right back
mark
60 seconds this is the tony michaels
podcast
[Music]
are you annoyed by masks infringing on
your rights do you wish you didn't have
to comply with biden's communist mask
mandate are you tired of wearing masks
that actually fit your face
well now you don't have to be
introducing the drew with our patented
droop technology every mask is uniquely
molded to not fit your face just send us
a selfie and we'll have one of our
troopests mold the mask for you elastic
free thanks to the droop i don't even
need to pull my mask on anymore it just
sags that way the droop lets you
customize from a selection of pre-worn
masks lipstick stains included make sure
to order your droop today drew be the
spread you want to see in the world
catch tony's twitch stream the [ __ ] list
roundup at twitch.tv slash the tony
michaels
we're back to the king of brilliant this
is the tony michaels podcast
[Music]
[Music]
welcome welcome welcome back to the show
thanks for hanging with us
through the break
what do you think about the gay brand
he's getting better at that and he
needed them on fire on fire this week
about this thing
it just uh
it really is [ __ ] stupid that we have
to do this [ __ ] in this in this day and
age that we have to tell people that you
can't you can't you can't threaten
people's lives like that's not a thing
that you can do you really you really
shouldn't do that that's not that's not
a cool thing like i thought we learned
this a long time ago but maybe we didn't
maybe we didn't and you can't threaten
them or their [ __ ] families calling
their [ __ ] families
there is nothing there is nothing that
pisses a real man off a real man i'm not
danno not [ __ ] portnoy not these
[ __ ] schoolies not these [ __ ]
alpha cucks there is nothing that pisses
off a real man more
and make and makes them want to have a
conversation with someone than them
threatening their family trust me
i i doubt there's any real men out there
that wouldn't want to do that have a
conversation man to man with someone
over what they would [ __ ] say to
their family members
and i think that's the point if you
listen to the video of brett he's not
he's not threatening this guy he's not
coming after this guy he's just saying
hey you own up to it be a man own up to
it tell me what you said and apologize
apologize and i'll accept your apology
so i don't know how many more of these
phone calls they've gotten are gonna get
but it's probably gonna be a lot more
because these uh these fragile white
males they don't give up easily they're
entitled i i know these types i've seen
these types
but i just round these tights my whole
[ __ ] life
that's who they are i think that's why i
don't get the hate i don't get it i
don't i i was telling gabe this morning
uh in the dm i was telling him that
because i was una i i was i was i don't
respond to trolls you guys know i
[ __ ] give them crickets unless it's
like chris chris is probably here in the
chat chris are you here in the chat he's
not a troll anymore he's a hate watcher
and we like to have him here on the show
i would i would i would welcome any of
the stoolies any of the rogue knights to
come listen to this show
to see to see what macho machismo can do
right
i don't i don't hide that you know i
don't hide who i am or what i am
i don't i don't hide behind some kind of
[ __ ] false
false [ __ ] image i am who i am
i'm a white guy with a beard who's from
the midwest who sounds like a trumper i
[ __ ] i wear a goddamn red hat but i aim
i aim i aim my beliefs in the opposite
direction the way that they would say it
because i think that's what we should do
because i don't think you should hide
who you are
but that doesn't mean you don't you you
don't have to be decent just because you
think you're a man and you gotta pound
your chest
and you gotta hate women like [ __ ]
brian earlier brian suave or whatever
the [ __ ] his name is hating on [ __ ]
women
what is it any of your [ __ ] business
what what someone does with their
[ __ ] twitter account if they want to
post pictures of their boobs and twitter
allows them to do that shut the [ __ ] up
go do what you want to do on your
goddamn account stop being so goddamn
snowflakey and [ __ ] be worried about
what someone else is doing on theirs get
the [ __ ] out of here with that [ __ ]
if a woman wants to post pictures of her
body on her twitter account
she can do it it's her [ __ ] right
it's her [ __ ] account as long as she
ain't breaking terms of services [ __ ] a
man can do it too i've seen i seen
george han
[Laughter]
you guys know george george is one of my
favorites the for me rants he posted a
picture
he posted a picture it's one of the
quote tweets you gotta go back to that
thread and look at that thread
it's a fantastic thread it'll it'll take
you a couple hours
to go through it but you really should
go back to that thread of brian suave
because i'm sure brian i'm sure brian is
christian as he is and as godly as he is
he probably listens not only to [ __ ]
joe rogan but probably portnoy as well
he's probably a stooly would be my guess
that's why he's posting [ __ ] tweets
about how women shouldn't do this or
women shouldn't do that and your
brother's pinning us all in on that on
his [ __ ] tweet get the [ __ ] out of
here
get the [ __ ] out of here some of us